ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show very excited here uh just a
negative uh Co my third time Co thank
you fizer hey when something works it
works when it works it works my aunt and
uncle both got it we were at Carnegie
Hall and uh we had a great night there
of Comedy sold at Carnegie Hall roseb
Baker Mike feny and we do the show and
uh the next night we go to Carnegie
Music Hall in Pittsburgh another amazing
show uh on the way home I just started
feeling those knives in your in your uh
sinuses I'm like uh oh maybe then I my
aunt called me she goes can you test
because we both feel like [__] because
usually you don't even test anymore then
I test it I'm like okay but after three
days it's kind of it's over
um I I do want to say thank you to
anyone who came out to Carnegie Hall it
was a one of the best standup comedy
shows I've ever done it's this amazing
venue Louis was in the audience which is
like that's really awesome to have
somebody you know at that level of the
business come and enjoy it you know all
my uh managers and agents were there and
what you realize when you spend time
with your managers and agents is just
they're just so terrible I mean they're
you know they're just like I mean
they're exactly who they should be
here's what I'll say this is not a knock
on any of them by the way it sounds like
is but it's not they're exactly who they
should be everybody's behaving exactly
how they should my business manager the
man who's in charge of all my money went
to flight club and bought those little
sneaker the lobster sneakers what are
they Nike yeah the Nike Lobster sne this
is the man who manages my money he went
like a
15-year-old ditching uh High School to
flight club gets these lobsters sneakers
and then he puts the bands on the ends
like in the in the dressing room or
Green Room of carnegy Hall the man is
sitting
there with
the these sneakers and then he puts the
bands on the end of them yeah to to and
then Ray comp goes what are you doing
and then he goes oh it's like the claws
like you know the way they they they B
they bind the claws of the lobster yeah
he's put in Carnegie Hall he's putting
these bands on the outside of his shoes
and he's taking photos of the shoes and
putting them on
Instagram he's taking photos of the
shoes and putting them on Instagram
Carnegie Hall but he doesn't care they
don't care about Carnegie hle because
it's not like 20,000 people so to them
it's like they don't
understand you know like they're they're
just kind of
like I think some of them think it's
cool yeah I mean so this is what this is
what the guy the guy has uh you know
he's putting bands on the end of
his he want he just belonged to the
state fair there's nothing wrong with it
he just belongs at a state
fair go going up in a you know going to
a tent going here will you deep fry this
you know those tents they have at the
State Fair where they go we'll deep fry
your Rolex yeah give to us that's where
he belongs but you know it's good he's
managing all my money so
great A Nightmare on the way getting to
Pittsburgh I want to talk about this
because I think that there
are companies out there that uh they get
there's a certain and Airbnb was at this
point there's a certain point when there
are the famous quote there are two roads
diverged in a
wood which one are you going to take
take I warn a lot of companies and I do
it out of the goodness of my heart and
the reason that I'm correct is that I'm
a consumer I'm out there doing the
things seeing the value of
things um it's part of the job and I
warned Airbnb months and months ago
years
ago I saidou giving people a cleaning
fee of 400 something
dollars
and expecting them to clean the
house this is going to
get to be a problem people are not going
to
stomach that you're asking them to
swallow a $400 fee to do something that
you're making them do so I I called that
out years ago because of that I was
removed from the service you know but I
was correct Airbnb has lost so much
market share nobody's staying in airbnbs
anymore when somebody tells you they're
in an Airbnb it's almost like what's
wrong with you when somebody says that
oh we got an Airbnb go oh everybody's
back in hotels the airb thing is over
and I knew it I knew it I saw the hosts
getting weird about their houses getting
weird about the
rules how strict they were and how the
type of person that was attracted to
being an Airbnb host I could see it all
before it
materialized and they did not heed my
warning I'm going now to discuss another
company I see a similar problem and this
is called
clear
clear right now is becoming a problem of
Airbnb
proportions if you are not a frequent
traveler but even if you've been to an
airport you've probably noticed the the
little
clear vestibules whatever they call them
now you maybe you haven't because
they're actually not in a lot of
airports kiosks I don't even know what
to call
these clear is a service that allows you
to bypass the regular security line when
you are flying clear by the way is a
private company it's funny it reminds me
of when Patrice O'Neal on OA was like
once you find out the fed the Federal
Reserve is a private bank nothing's ever
the same for you like it's [__] clear
is a private Company the company in
charge of of of
security at the
airport which I thought was Affiliated
in some way with the government
is a private company I remember years
ago I was on a security line I had woken
up late I was like you know stressed out
and they see you and they pick you out
and they go
hey why don't you come over here and
sign up for clear and what clear is is
they take your biometric data they scan
your eyes and your fingerprint they run
you through a database and then you are
all clear you get to skip the line and
you get to go ahead of every body
else you don't need your ID they tell
you go you don't need your ID fly
without your ID you're going clear okay
they take your biometric data and then
they go boom there you go and the first
couple of times you do it it works
perfectly and you go this is a really
great idea wow look at me I'm clear you
start getting the airport 18 minutes
before the flight I mean it's crazy you
start trying to time it like I've missed
flights because I I've just
underestimated how long the clear line
would be because the clear has now a lot
of people so there's a line for clear
now in the beginning of it you would
just Breeze and sometimes now you still
Breeze clear
promised find out how many airports it's
in when when you signed up for Clear
they go we are gonna be
everywhere we are G to be everywhere
don't worry about it do not worry about
it they are now I believe
in it's not a lot what is it 26 airports
or something uh it's a few dozen yeah
it's a yeah it's like a few
dozen it's not a lot of airports uh okay
51 airports clear is now in 51
airports so
clear promises okay we're going to
we going to be everywhere they're not
everywhere there's certain terminals
that don't have clear you'll go to
terminals of airports that have clear
and they go yeah not terminal four yeah
we don't do clear and you go okay now
the clear experience has also kind of
become a hell the people that work at
Clear let's just can we use the term
GED these are not people that have
graduated high school with the region
diploma or whatever kind of diploma you
get no it's the people that are in a GED
of course they're not the most motivated
group of
people uh the people that work at Clear
act like you've done something wrong
when you need their help they couldn't
be less interested in helping you they
could not be less interested in getting
you through this thing in a timely
fashion they are lazy and they do not
care I don't know where clear finds
these people perhaps there are people
that aren't good enough God forbid
imagine this to be in the regular TSA
they couldn't muster up the competence
to be in the regular TSA so they now
handle clear and they could not care
less the other thing clear now does is a
random ID check every time the whole
point of clear was like hey it's quick
you don't need your ID it's you know
it's boom you cut the line we're taking
your [__] biometric data so that we
do not need your ID we're you're
scanning my
retina why would you need an idea you're
retina I pay you money I scan my
fingerprint my one of
one bio identifier what's the [__]
big deal so I get to Newark about I
don't know 30 40 minutes before my
flight takes off maybe 20 minutes before
it closes you know like 20 minutes
before the flight uh closes I don't I
don't know who these people are I get so
many people calling these like I've I've
so many like and I talked to a lot of
them these uh tele marketers well yeah
te telemarketer and people but it's just
telemarketing and I watch that
documentary on HBO The telemarketers oh
yeah it was really good Doc and it was
fun but telemarketing in G it's so bad
now no one's good no one's even good at
it and they're not even telemarketing
for anything that has any value they're
just it's just like health insurance
insurance and stuff like long-term care
it's like what um so I go to nework and
I go listen I got I got a I got a
problem here I go I don't have my ID but
I'm a member of clear I say this to the
clear people and they're just staring at
me because they're all high and I mean
crazy high like the the the level of
high the people are at Clear it's
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing how
[__] up they all are they just see
shapes they don't even know what's
happening they're just staring at you
and you're just a loud shape like an
undulating sphere in front of them so
they're just staring at you like I'm not
speaking The King's English when I say
this and I say hey I don't have an ID
I'm a clear member that shouldn't be an
issue and they're
like they're like we'll see I go yeah
okay they run me through three times
each time they want a random ID
check each time again after scanning my
eyes and my thumb guys what are we
doing so then they bring me to the
person uh who's supposed to sign off you
know well clear afterwards somebody has
to walk you from the clear thing to the
security uh you know line and then you
know clear with the person who's
checking in all the regular people and
go look this person's clear and show
them your boarding pass I go here's my
boarding pass so they bring me up they
go this guy doesn't have an ID they go
okay we'll try to get a supervisor I
stand there 20 minutes no super
supervisor comes from the regular TSA
like nobody comes they don't even come
and tell me to [__] off I have a copy of
my license on my phone I have a photo of
my passport on my phone I'm like I left
my passport at my house I have these
photos and I'm clear meaning that they
just scanned my [__]
eyes and it's me and no one cares still
no one cares not only does no one care
but nobody tries to help okay the clear
Line is now getting pretty long and now
people have left the clear people do
this sometimes you'll show up to the
airport and then the clear people have
gone away they're no longer working
they're at lunch truly they are gone
they're somewhere else so now you've
paid money to be part of this service
that operates when it
wants they are they kind of operate when
and God forbid you have a problem and
this idea that if you don't have an ID
you can't get on a plane I thought the
whole premise of clear was that we have
your
bioinformation so if God forbid there's
ever an issue you're okay you're a
member of
clear and that wasn't the case and I'm
just saying out there to all of the
clear people that may or may not hear
this message it's becoming a cumbersome
process that's not enjoyable for people
they try to sell you things they try to
get you add people onto your clear while
you're going through clear It's never
enough can you add this person you know
it might make sense you're traveling is
this your first time traveling yeah why
don't you add him to your account that
way you can get
through that way he can have all the
problems that you have with this service
I'm just saying it's going to be one of
those things where if they improve it
because it does the premise of it is
good if it's improved it's
great but this idea this random Ida
check all the [__] time which slows
everybody down they check everyone's
everybody's rifling to get their idea
what well then what are we all doing
here why don't you just
do it's the same thing we'll all bring
our
ID and then you just let us cut the line
why are we paying to be in a bio
security system did has no value because
we're [__] people are getting your ID
or forbid if they don't have their ID
and I mean I know it's not a problem
everyone has like a lot of people have
their ID but this is a problem that
people can have people lose a wallet
they leave it in an Uber something
happens and they go [__] at least can I
get home right I'm a member of clear and
then clear's like I don't
[Music]
know also why don't you just hire a few
people that are not straight out of
rehab like a just a few people on the
clear team that aren't straight out of
like a work release program if you could
because everybody there could not be
more out of it it makes the regular TSA
look amazing and the regular TSA is
horrible for the most part not all of
them but I mean have you ever I mean
Christ almighty the regular TSA is bad
enough the people on clear it's like God
damn it what happened
here so that's my War that's just my
warning for or clear it doesn't mean
that uh it doesn't mean that it's going
to have the same fate as Airbnb but it
just might it just might if people don't
get their act together you know and it's
just like they don't explain the situ
the clear people just drop you off they
go yeah he doesn't have an ID he wants
to fly that's your whole service that's
the whole thing I signed up for they act
like I'm nuts when I when I signed up
they go yeah you don't even need your ID
mhm because you're in the system and
then they look at me like he doesn't
have an ID he's [__] lunatic he's
probably a terrorist he doesn't want to
fly instead of just being like this
man doesn't have ID
however you know he's in our system he
flies all the time he's got it on his
phone like there was no nobody's trying
to help you there so that I had to fly
private which I didn't want to do I
didn't want to waste the money thank God
our jet broker Dirk
is was available that day unless I would
have missed a show in Carnegie Music
Hall which ended up being a great show
but I'm just saying these are the things
that unfortunately you notice when you
travel a lot and traveling is terrible
now
because everybody's overworked I've
mentioned it a lot everybody's stretched
to their
limit flight attendants you could see in
their face want the plane to crash
you could see it when they take
off like in bad turbulence some of them
just smile now they want to die because
we've made it terrible for them we've
let monsters on the any
time I'm on a plane that doesn't have an
incident there's no shouting screaming
or anything there's no hygiene issues
there's no I mean thank God I'm like I'm
because it's a zoo and it's become a zoo
and the pilots and flight attendants and
the crew all are so fed up with dealing
with people and every day there's a
report of some near miss two planes
grazing each other you
know British Airways crew claimed they
were mugged in Brazil had spent the
whole night drinking forcing flight to
be cancelled I don't even blame them the
people that are up in the air right now
are all using some type of uh drug to
get through it just to get through it
they're on drugs or they're drinking the
pilots every all of them you know that
movie Flight that's all of them all the
time where they're all if they have 48
hours before their next flight it is a
nonstop drug and alcohol binge from when
they land the plane to when they get
back on again they have the shakes when
they get back on because
it is so traumatic flying now with
members of the American public M they
have no idea what's going to transpire
who's going to open a door who's going
to open that hatch in the middle of the
air they have to land you know that so
people are basically just like yeah as
soon as I get off this plane shoot me up
with Heroin until I get back on because
I can't stand it people are disgusting
they're violent they're drunk they're on
drugs they don't know what's going on
they don't know what seat they're in
they're fighting each other in the sky
30,000 feet in the sky and these people
who are getting paid little not a lot of
money have to deal with it the pilots
can't leave the cockpit so it's the
flight attendants that have to deal with
the chaos the pilots are not allowed to
leave because somebody will run in and
do a 911 so if you got a military pilot
in there who could maybe go in the back
and go hey what the [__] going on but
you can't do that because the minute the
cockpit door opens some lunatic runs in
and they try to do 911 again so it's all
the flight attendants that have to deal
with the entire thing so I'm just saying
top to bottom which is why I'm very
happy I got a few more months of of live
shows which we love and I'm taking you
know eight months or a year while I
won't be on the road the way I've been
on the road because I've been touring
since 201 21 on and off I've been on a
lot of planes I've been on a lot of
flights international domestic
everywhere everywhere from [__]
Auckland New Zealand uh you know to
Dallas right I've been all over the
world and I will say that there's
nothing quite like um you know United
flight or an American Airlines flight
there's nothing quite like a
rockus American Airlines flight or Delta
or God forbid Southwest I don't fly
Southwest although they see to be a bit
friendlier like the people in Southwest
seem to be a little happier that they're
you know but there's nothing like a
group of entitled Americans and a lot of
the Boomers now are fly like the boomers
are flying in in in large numbers now
and the boomers are flying to go visit
and torture and torment their children
this is why boomers are traveling all
over the country is to go to where their
children have been forced to live and
laugh at them this is what Boomers like
to do they go that you pay this for that
that's the whole point anytime a boomer
gets in a plane it is so that the plane
can land and they can go uh to their
child uh their children's house and go
oh my God this is what this is what you
are living in this is how you live and
the reason for that is because Boomers
refuse to sell their houses boomers are
85 years old riddled with four cancers
and will not sell their house unless
they make $900,000
they have impoverished an entire
generation of people that cannot get
into the real estate market because
Boomers themselves refuse to leave
there's all kinds of articles about this
now and it's hilarious Boomers will not
relinquish their hold on Suburban real
estate in America they won't they won't
do it if they
took a little less money for example for
their house if the Boomers went you know
what I'll take a little less money for
this house and I'll I'll just put it
back on the market so that someone
else could have a shot but boomers are
sitting there they've got 17 pills they
take every day just to stay
alive and they pick up the phone and the
real estate agent goes maybe we could do
this we can get you this and they go
absolutely not
absolutely not you will never get this
house for under
1.9 they refuse to leave because it's
their biggest
Cuda the the the Boomer having a
mcmansion in in a place like Long Island
is the thing that they have that allows
them to they're the lord of the manner
and they can they can impress upon their
children what failures they are because
they don't live in the in the style that
the Boomers live in now the Boomers of
course will leave out all the advantages
they had to get said house but they will
not relinquish that because that is the
thing that they have you know this is
the thing that they have this is the way
that they judge it was an article why
Boomers will not move
into uh more size appropriate homes
which I love because boomers
are you know if if anything they
are selfish they like themselves which
makes them funny that's what makes them
really really funny um and the reason
that they won't leave these houses is
because they cannot
imagine trying to
live in in in a more simple way even in
like the Twilight of their days in the
Twilight of their days they need more
space and then their Millennial children
can't afford any of this so they're on
planes now complaining about everything
waiting for the plane to land so their
first stop is going to go to their
children's house and then go oh my God
you're it's so small here it's very
small I mean I feel so bad for your gen
you know when we were coming I mean we
worked harder than you guys of course
and we had a lot more to deal with but
you know at least you got something for
your money you got a little something
it's like you're the reason you the
reason we we have the oldest Congress in
American history these people will not
retire Boomers hold on for dear life to
everything to everything they are
falling down in the halls of Congress
they will not leave they will not quit
this is why the world looks the way it
does it's being run exclusively by like
elderly Boomers who will not leave they
they are afraid of not running the show
um you know they will not yeah according
to a recent Mara Lynch retirement study
of more than 3600 respondents 49% of
retirees didn't downsize in their last
move and 30% actually ended up moving
into larger homes this is how sick
some of these people are they go I'm a
100 and I want more I want a bigger home
I want a bigger home to show my kids
what losers they really are that's
really what it comes down to I want a
mansion now to show my kids how much
better I've done than them they will not
let go they will not like Diane what's
her name a Feinstein died in office she
was a corpse for years years died in all
our president he will not step aside he
won't step
aside it's it's it's kind of a common
thing to the the whole Boomer thing is
just hold on to it hold on for dear life
but I see them you know when you get on
a plane obviously there's people of all
ages but you'll just kind of keying on
the Boomers and they're just kind is
very
judgmental and you know they're in like
economy plus you know they paid just a
little bit more they paid just a little
bit more so they can harass the flight
attendant a standard deviation more than
the people in the back they have a
little bit of status and maybe some of
them are in first who knows but they're
all just traveling to some City where
their children live and they can go and
judge them for how they live right and
they never make the connection that oh
none of us have put our homes back on
the market none of us have God forbid
taken a little bit less and simplified
Our
Lives you know so that we have we're
effectively locking out because by the
way guess who loves the Black Rock and
everybody giving everybody crazy money
the Boomers they go yeah you you give me
that two million they love it they love
it they'll tell you one of the favorite
pastimes of anyone over a certain age
they'll tell you what they can get for
their house immediate you don't you
don't even ask you do not even and they
do it on holidays like onist chras and
stuff they didn't they know why they're
doing it too they know exactly why
they're doing it they sit immediately
they go yeah yeah they go you want to
hear something crazy and you're like and
usually when someone says that you want
to hear something crazy you would think
they're going to tell you something
crazy you know like some crazy story
they heard when a boomer says you want
to hear something crazy they just want
to tell you the exact amount of money
they have that's exact they go no no no
come here listen to this I bought this
for 200,000 you know what they tell me I
could get now 1.8 isn't that something
but guess what I ain't leaving friend or
two and they're telling this to the
people that are in mired in student loan
debt okay that are living in an
apartment where the rent is being raised
every year and they're trying to hold on
and the whole Boomer thing is to just go
pick this up for a pretty penny pick
this up for almost nothing and now this
is you know pretty good it's worth a lot
of money um
it's
amazing how unhealthy our society is is
truly amazing the 30% of Boomers moving
into larger homes to retire is genuinely
one of the funniest things I've ever
heard we have a housing crisis in
America we have a housing shortage in
the country there are people right now
that have been locked out of
homeownership for a decade maybe more
because of the price of homes and the
interest rates right now things would
have to Tumble so much to just get back
to a regular and boomers are responding
to that by saying hey we're going up
we're actually scaling up we've decided
there's a few more rooms we have we
don't need to use you know it is kind of
amazing Mary balsas from our friends at
manscape the holidays are approaching
but what if I told you that the
celebration is starting early this year
turns out that the perfect gift does
exist and who else to bring it down your
chimney and the leaders in below the
waist grooming you know who I'm talking
about folks it's manscaped their brand
new performance package 5.0 Ultra
featuring the new lawn mower 5.0 watch
all your wishes and mistletoe kisses
come true look nice when you're getting
naughty by going to manscape.com use
code Tim D for 20% off plus free
shipping unwrap the gift of smoothness
this season with manscape everybody uses
manscape and should if you're not you're
crazy the other things on the market
like to Relic body groom kind of suck
mans gate performance package 5.0 is the
ultimate bundle for a man who deserves
it all including in the special sack is
a lawn mower 5.0 the weed whacker 2.0
ear and nose trimmer which also comes in
handy manscapes liquid formulation and
two free gifts starting with Santa's
number one helper we have the lawnmower
5.0 Ultra this fifth generation trimmer
features two next gen blade heads a
standard trimmer blade for taking a
little off the top and new foil blade to
for that smooth finish wherever your
heart
desires get 20% off free shipping with
code timd manscape.com that's 20% off
with free shipping at manscape.com and
yours code timd manscape get your jingle
balls ready for the holidays folks I'm
telling you right now e-commerce thrives
during the holiday season but if you're
doing an e-commerce business at all in
any capacity the last thing you need to
be doing is worrying about your back
office you need to be worrying about the
origination of new clients marketing and
of course the ideas the engine of your
business whatever it is you're doing you
know edging out the competition being
better being sharper smarter more unique
more original you do not need to be
worrying about shipping so you need a
service like ship station that automates
that entire process they work with all
the major carriers they set up an easy
interface that shows you what's got sent
out what's been received USPS UPS get
discounts up to 84% off both of those
130,000 companies have scaled their
e-commerce businesses with ship station
98% of all companies that stick with
ship station for a year become customers
for life isn't that amazing you could
quickly and easy update crucial order
information reducing errors they work
with Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more
go to shipstation.com use promo code Tim
Dylan and get your free 60-day trial so
literally this entire holiday season
you're using shipstation for free
automating everything your entire back
office 60 days for free ship station
if you use the code Tim Dyan t m d i l n
i mean that's a great deal and it's a
great way to make your business
efficient and profitable pretty early on
I may uh ship my dead schizophrenic
mother's art by using ship station
Zuckerberg is out there Mark Zuckerberg
is out there doubling down on the
metaverse he for a while we thought like
the metaverse might be dead or that the
metaverse you know
maybe all future Wars will be fought in
the metaverse I was thinking about that
the other day I'm like you know we all
we all you know or I certainly do I
bemoan the idea of everything becoming
digital right this idea of like a
complete digital sphere that we all must
exist in but then you look at the
Carnage happening all over the world
specifically in Gaza right now right and
you go God if we could find a way to
digitize
conflict why are you making a face well
it just it sounds very
matrixyl right thank you yeah it's very
Matrix that's the [__] point that's
the thing you know the growth in
parasocial relationships is Big you know
that everybody saw that movie Her M
everybody saw that movie her where
Walkin Phoenix was in love with his you
know a Siri or whatever and everybody
was like wow that's far out well it's
not far out it's actually here there's a
lot of power social relation people have
them with comedians they have them with
celebrities they have them with
influencers they have them with only
fans but the people that are on the
internet all the time there's people
that feel like they are dating
them oh the he I'm dating him if I just
knew him if I just met him I'd be his
girlfriend I got a sh shot that's how
crazy the parasocial realm of this has
become there are people right now
everyone has turned into a little bit of
a stalker with the way that things are
now everybody who enjoys anything is a
little bit of a stalker now they're like
well you know o they he he ated that
restaurant I've been there I wonder if
he'll go there later like it is a little
weird the idea of how
attached people get to people on the
internet and they have this power social
thing where they feel like they're your
friend or your girlfriend you just don't
know it yet that by the way used to be
what schizophrenics thought like if you
climbed
into Taylor Swift's
backyard you were a
schizophrenic because you were a stalker
and someone had to shoot you like one of
her security had to come with a gun and
kill you
now if you send her messages and you
look up her house on Zillow and you read
every article about her and you know
you're a good fan now you're a good fan
you know you purchase uh you love a
comedian you buy a meet and greet or you
yell out something during the show cuz
you're like I just want to speak to this
per again it used to be disruptive now
you're a good fan because the level of
power social has grown to a point where
people are no longer happy and content
to enjoy the thing that someone's doing
they have to be a part of it which used
to be the realm of stalkers it used to
be the realm of someone who is a problem
like that's an issue you know but the
attachment that people have now on the
internet to people they've never met and
probably will never meet but they
believe in their head that they'd be
great
friends or romantically involved with
said person is
crazy and it's not a comment on the
person out there it's a comment on some
fan bases or some people out there and I
think it's across the board I don't even
think it's just hot people I think it's
people that people find uh quirky or
interesting or it's like the attachment
that people have to people is unhealthy
but it is seemingly
irreversible meaning I brought this up
at to dinner the other day people are
like what do you mean and I'm like we
got one like because you know people
will casually tell you they've messaged
someone every month or every week for as
long as they've known that per they go
yeah occasionally I'll get a message
back and I go oh yeah but you shouldn't
that's crazy they go so so what I
understand you message me and you're
like you Zionist Peg you don't ever call
like one guy goes don't ever call
yourself Irish again you Zionist Peg P
I'm like number one I don't call myself
Irish I don't [__] in the street my
family left Ireland and we came to the
new world okay um and I don't know what
makes me as Z's Pig other than having
this uh Noah dis be on who's gonna
co-host the show now um she just hasn't
shown up the last couple of
episodes but what I'm what I'm saying is
like the parasocial realm is very
interesting so that that was the one
thing that's very interesting to me it
feels like an irreversible thing it it
doesn't feel like it's going away and I
I I think this thing uh this this
metaverse thing that Mark Zuckerberg has
been pushing which essentially is just a
more immersive social media experience
than the one you have now augmented
reality virtual reality whatever and his
company has been pushing this I remember
during the insanity of
um the nft at the height of the nft I
feel like an old but you know at the
height of the nft Gold Rush right the
metaverse was talked about people came
to me and I was in Miami they go you got
to be the first comedian in the
metaverse you got to be the first comic
because there were like little comedy
clubs in the metaverse where you would
perform virtually to groups of people
and there were people out there that
would be like oh wow this is
so so the reality is
Zuckerberg's
dream and all of this stuff by the way
about tech and we'll add all these
articles and post but all of this stuff
all of these studies are coming out now
about how detrimental Tech is for
teenagers it's causing higher rates of
suicide it's causing uh a lot of image
issues body image issues it's causing an
uptick and
anxiety specifically amongst young women
but also young men like a anxiety and
depression are huge now for teenagers
because of
tech social media and mental health I
mean this is this this is the
huge thing that tech companies really
don't want to hear they don't want to
hear about this at all they don't want
to hear about how vulnerable children
are being
exploited uh for profit and we're
ruining a lot of their lives and their
mental health they don't want to hear it
and
and their whole thing is I think Mark
Zuckerberg's probably he goes yeah but
you know why that is there's still an
outside world we haven't transition
fully into the metav once we're fully
in once we've all uploaded our
Consciousness once we're fully in the
metaverse we'll take care of it but yeah
it's probably confusing for those kids
that they still they're still in
outside people are now staying inside
more this is a big article that I read
the other day cities are lonelier
American downtowns are being abandoned
that's for many reasons but people are
online more people are spending more
time on their computers we never
can um you know we we've never kind of
fully came back from covid when the
exponential growth of of digital stuff
got really wild and we're still we're
still there and we're probably going to
stay there it doesn't show any signs of
abating like this idea that most social
interactions are originating
online children now are digitally
native Zoom meetings for work people
working in hybrid work environments um
all of this stuff doesn't seem to be
going away uh certain people have
doubled down on it and zugerberg is is
basically going out now and saying
hey you know we need to we need to get
in
here pretty soon I think we're going to
be at a point where you're going to be
there physically with some of your
friends and others will be there
digitally as avatars or Holograms and
they'll feel just as present as everyone
else or you'll walk into a meeting and
sit down at a table there will be people
who are there physically and people who
are there digitally but also sitting
around the table with you are going to
be a bunch of AI guys who who are
embodied as Holograms and are helping
you get different stuff done
too that's his dream that's the guy's
dream that's where we're
going this is where this is where he's
been
going and and and Boomers won't die
first they'll be there so you're gonna
have your racist
ant digitally there at Christmas what if
Boomers upload their cont Consciousness
and never leave what if they never leave
what if right as they're going to
die a switch gets flipped and all of a
sudden you know everything becomes
possible and just for all eternity you
know people are like oh my God hello I'm
here I you know I don't really miss my
body as much as I thought I would like
they just never leave it's very possible
they never leave and this man is doing
that Mark Zuckerberg is giving them hope
he's giving them hope they go [__] could
sell my house I might not even die I
might be around forever if I'm a
hologram why would I need a smaller
house if I'm a hologram what does that
mean I work my whole life to be a
hologram I'm going to live in a smaller
house just cuz I'm a
hologram it's it's getting to a point
where it's crazy but I'm I'm reading a
lot of this stuff and a lot of is very
interesting there's a book right now
called the dimensions of the cave which
I just started reading which is very
fascinating and it's about art
artificial intelligence and you know
creating AI people eventually it's about
a journalist a fiction book it's about a
journalist who uncovers a secret
government program um that's creating
these people um and it it it does
seem interesting to be at this point
because at this
point it does seem like there's ample
evidence to go out there and go hey we
need to
limit
technology in in in in a myriad of ways
but specifically for for developing
adolescence you have to limit it there's
mountains of evidence all it's all back
now we have all the evidence now all the
evidence is in we should limit
technology however we have all the
evidence on TiK ToK by the way and I
mean you know we know what it is we know
what Tik Tok is now you don't have to
I'm not saying you have to ban it or
whatever but we we know what it is we
know forget the privacy concerns we we
know what problems are there we know
what issues there are um you know we
know that it is your your data your your
information it is going and you know but
that's all of these places right it's
why we can't take uh the Republicans
seriously when they start yelling and
screaming about Tik
Tock I love how by the way something uh
I thought of this the other day it all
started with Donald Trump being like an
agent of Russia you know and now
literally the thing that they're getting
him on is that he inflated the price of
his condo like that's how far it's
fallen and by the way who's the victim
of that State Farm Lloyds of London like
an insurance company it's just so funny
that like it started with like he was
hand selected by Russia he's been
working with them for years and they
elected him and now he's the president
and then after none of that came true
four years later they're like he said it
was worth 38 million it would barely
sell for 29 it's like that what
that's what you got M after doing all
the digging and finding all of the
things after marshalling all of the
resources to pull that guy apart for
years the thing you get him on is that
he inflated the price of real estate
which every developer every owner
everybody has always that's the whole
point of owning real estate is to say
it's worth more than it is and get
someone to buy that and believe that
that's every homeowner in in in in the
BBS going up to the appraiser and going
well I think this is about 600,000 right
and apprais like I don't know we'll see
yeah well I'm just telling you I think
that's what you know up the block that
guy sold for 650 he doesn't even got you
know I got a bar in my back where he
doesn't even have that so this idea that
the only thing we're able to get the guy
on MH outside of the January 6 stuff but
like you know which is is formidable I
get it but like this idea that Americans
are going to be enraged that he inflated
the price of his assets that Americans
are going to be like I can't believe it
well that office building he said was
worth 300 million in downtown that was
probably 170 million at best people
can't even comprehend these numbers
these are not even comprehensible
numbers to the vast majority of people
that live and draw breath on our planet
they have no idea Manhattan real you
cannot explain Manhattan real estate to
people that don't live here they don't
understand they don't understand why an
office building's worth
$300 million the entire operating budget
of like the county they live in one
building and the idea that people are
going to be like impassioned by this we
are
disgusted we are dis disgusted that he
would inflate the price yeah it's all
it's all anyone does by the way it's all
and let's go open the books on everybody
let's go open the books on all of these
billionaires are you telling me that
billionaires are inflating the price of
their assets to get
loans you can't be serious I am shock I
am by the way Bill Clinton on Epstein's
jet 20 never reported not reported
barely couple articles no one really
cares no one cares multiple times some
without a secret service the biggest
human trafficker that we know of he's on
a plane about no one cares Donald Trump
they're like well you know that that's
not worth what he said it was right he
said it had eight bathrooms it has six
it has a powder room that's a powder
room it's not a full bathroom that's not
a full bathroom it's a powder room it's
psyonic that's it's not an Eden kitchen
what are you nuts you see he said it was
Eden what about the guy that was on the
human traffickers plate well he's been
honest about his assets that's what I
care about I care about somebody honest
about their assets if you say it's a
fifth bedroom but it's set up as an
office and it doesn't have a window it's
not a bedroom you go what I don't know
she's very fun it's such a funny thing
only because it started at the fever
pitch of he was in stalled by the
Russian government you got to remember
that's how it started it started as he
is a now there's reasons to not like
Donald Trump there's reasons to not want
him back as president but it's very
funny to me to start like it's like if
the the the principal of your school
called you in and they were like uh we
think your son is a school shooter and
you go oh my God what happened did you
find a
Manifesto what what did you I mean oh my
God you're crying you're on the way
there with your husband our baby's the
killer what did we do wrong I can't
believe and you get there and you find
out that like the reason that they think
your kid is a school shooter is they
found him like you know with his friends
like doing some dumb Tick Tock dance
with a gun thing that there's like
there's a gun like in the Tik Tock dance
there's like a gun like a rap and it's
like some song and that's why they're
all upset and you go wait that's why you
think he's going to murder everybody
yeah well we saw him dancing with a guy
his fake little gun there and you go
what are you an idiot I mean that's what
it that's what the Trump thing feels
like it feels like you start so
high you can't cash those checks and
then you get down and then now we're at
he's infl I mean can you imagine by the
way it started at it is the biggest
Russian intelligence operation in human
history they've got they they've
installed the president it was the
that's the like premise of films right
that's the premise of films that Russia
has stalled the president of the United
States he's being blackmailed by the
Kremlin because he likes to get peed on
by Russian
[__] and now the movie and now so
that's a good movie you pitch that man
I'm all ears I work at a [__] Sony
whatever big movie studio I'm I'm into
that movie I go so wait a minute so
Russia installed this President they're
blackmailing him they got a p tape it's
[__]
great sit with me for this pitch all
right hey thanks for meeting with us
today okay get this right so the guy's
really rich okay he owns real estate he
inflates the price of
it well here's what I mean by
that market value might be like 200
million he says it's worth like 280
yeah think of that is that not good is
that not a great movie is that not
[__] compelling is that not
compelling to you a rich guy saying he
has more money than he does like every
rich guy is that not a compelling film
but that's how the movie Changed by the
way that's how the movie changed from
this guy was installed by a foreign
government who's been blackmailing him
for years to um yeah I mean he's that
condo is not worth
that that's literally how it's changed I
love ear earphones I love listening to
music earbuds pods whatever you call
them but raycon is the product I have
they they made a name for themselves in
the audio space products like their
everyday earbuds known for delivering
high quality and thoughtful features
like 32-hour battery life and perfect in
fit and this past year they expanded
their business with the introduction of
raycon home and raycon power Tech it's
amazing their five-star reviewed magic
180 cable allows you to charge iOS micro
USB and type-c devices eight times
faster with 100 mat power I love this I
have it I use it it's essential to have
in your house rayon is own for
delivering high quality and thoughtful
features at half the price of other
premium Tech Brands it's no wonder their
products have racked up tens of
thousands of five star reviews this is
one of the only competitors for you know
who and they have cheap products that
are durable and great and you can use
them all the
time to get everyone in the holiday
shopping Spirit a bit early Ray con is
currently offering 20% off everything on
their site with select products up to
50% off Ray con is currently offering
20% off everything on their site with
select products up to 50% off so beat
the crowds and safe now trust me you do
not want to miss out on rayon's early
Black Friday sale you don't hurry now to
buy ron.com to get 20 to 50% off
sitewide that's by raycon.com Tim to
score up to 50% off raycon products by
raycon.com Tim so now the rap Young Thug
this rapper Who's going away for a long
time here I think they are now going to
use his lyrics against him in
prosecution this is something that has
been happening lyrics can be used as
evidence during rapper Young Thugs trial
on gang and racketeering charges let me
catch everybody up to speed that isn't
aware of
this in
rap people rap about crimes they
committed sometimes and a lot of those
crimes are very very accurate like they
literally say exactly what they
did and now prosecutors are able to take
those lyrics and say this is not you
don't have this artistic license you're
describing uh something that happened
in visceral detail and we're going to
use it against you here is my message to
the RAP
Community as a whole because I have some
advice and you might look at me and go
wait a minute you don't have advice I do
um and this is uh this is my message for
the people in the community of drill rap
and other types of
rap if you kill Frank on Sixth Street
let's just say
that why not say you killed Bill on
Eighth
Street I'm not saying probably Frank and
Bill are not the names of the people
that are involved in this perhaps I'm
just in my own head to keep it straight
if you and I don't want to sound racist
here but you're going to sound racist by
just saying what I'm going to say but
it's not racist it's just I'm trying to
approximate this okay if you kill
thean in the Bronx say you killed
Rosario in
Queens make it up you don't have to be
that I know it's
credibility if you say the actual guy
you don't H you can just fudge it
it's you can fudge it I know people have
gotten very comfortable now where they
could just literally go on and talk
about a h a murder they committed but
they are all the cop they are listening
so just fudge
it go around
it throw people for a loop throw them
for a loop you know use fake names use
fake locations you could still get the
message cross is my point my point is
you can still get the message across you
don't have to
be glaringly accurate about every murder
that you've committed every single
murder that you've committed you're
going to be accurate you like yeah we
[__] right outside of the bodega on 17 I
shot him in the head and it's like hey
hey he hey hey hey
hey say it's the fish spot on
79th and you could have a fun little
chart in the room when you're writing
Rhymes you could go I said what did we
really do well we shot this guy outside
of the bodega change Bodega to fish spot
and say we shot a
woman what about that that'll really
that'll throw everybody for a loop but
you have to lie you have to lie like
comedians we'll make stuff up sometimes
people make stuff up not me
others my point is is that a judge has
said that lyrics will be admissible as
evidence in the trial of star us rapper
Young
Thug a lot of people are not into it
it's been decried by Free Speech groups
like Jay-Z and Coldplay I love Coldplay
Coldplay's like don't use our lyrics
don't use our lyrics to call us
[__] like cplay somehow involved in
this don't you dare use lyrics against
people you might listen to our songs and
think we're [__] but that's not true
don't use our
lyrics there's a lot of people going
down right now 28 people were initially
charged including uh another chart
topping rapper gunana Who's got great
music I love all of their music by the
way and the way I feel and this is a
controversial thing
but I say let sleeping dogs lie and
here's what I mean by this can't
everyone start with a fresh
slate like they should go to a lot of
these rappers go okay The Killing stops
now
and then if they don't kill anymore it's
like okay because it's part of the thing
it's part of the game I don't condone
it prosecutor Simone Hilton quoted
lyrics in court quote I just beat a
murder rap I paid my lawyer 30 for that
there's a few other lyrics in between
that and then me and my slimes are above
the law well people you
know yeah well this is the thing this is
why you have to MH start rapping about
the cops being good throw everyone for a
loop throw them for a loop you can still
do the killing you can still go out
there and do the killing and throw
everyone for a loop Eric Adams is the
man the cops are who I
stand you know it ain't easy to be a
[__] cop you know like it may maybe
that maybe that's the move maybe like
you go the other way if you're a real
Gangster and you're ordering hits and
killing people maybe maybe you go the
other way and just do do the Candace
Owens thing Candace Owens could be
ordering hits all over the hood we never
know we would never
know so that might be the move that
might be the move the move might be the
more violent you are actually you just
stay very like you
know Pro cops you know their new song
that they're coming out with um which is
I don't know if this is a little suspect
but Young Thug new song Israel has a
right to defend
[Laughter]
itself
feels I don't know it just feels you
know
slightly a little patronizing perhaps a
little opportunistic young thug and gun
is new song Israel has the right to
defend itself
Shalom seems odd see we didn't talk
about Israel and Palestine I know some
of you were like we're getting we're
getting two in the Weeds about Israel
and Palestine but I'll tell you this um
I think it's better now I think
everyone's turning the corner MH I
believe that everyone feels that way um
I think Hamas has
negotiated the release of some hostages
we're not going to get in the Weeds on
it I'm just saying I believe that's the
case I'm
not I I agree with you because by the
way I get upset with it too I get bored
with it too you don't think I'm bored
with it but it is the biggest story in
the
world so when things are the biggest
story in the world you have to say
hey
Houston Texas there's maybe no tickets
left by the time oh yeah probably for
Saturday night two shows on Saturday
night if this comes out in the morning
San Diego Detroit Toronto Austin break
California for New Year Columbus Ohio
Bethlehem Pennsylvania Washington DC
Northfield Ohio San Antonio Dallas
Atlanta St Louis Indianapolis Boston uh
Foxwoods Atlantic City stand up live
will be announced very soon uh Dania
Beach Improv being announced soon too
Fort Lauderdale having some fun
having some fun before we take a little
break here the movie Thanksgiving with
Eli Roth on Addison Ray Rick Hoffman
Gina gershan Patrick Dempsey Milo
Manheim Tomaso sinelli Tim Dylan and
others there are others I just can't
remember everybody's name is coming out
today it's out
today how fun is that big news big
news very cool well we thank everyone
for listening all the time we thank you
for seeing us uh supporting us here and
patreon and um you know it's um it's
always a joy and an honor to do this
show we are uh with you twice a week um
and then we will see you uh on the big
screen if you go to Thanksgiving we hope
you enjoy that as well and um The Wilbur
Theater in Boston we're gonna be doing a
special there in February grab tickets
we'll do a few shows there um ticket
links up so good luck everyone and again
to the drill RAP Community I'm a fan I
enjoy it again if you kill Bill on
12th you actually we killed Ralph on
Fifth if you killed it's like clue if
you killed Bill by shooting him outside
of the bodega say you killed Ralph with
a knife by the fish spot not a big deal
that way the cops and the da is going
wait a minute we got Bill dad with a
gunshot wound they're saying they stab
Ralph by the fish spot do you see how it
works do you see how easy it is do you
see how nice it is do you see how nice
life can be if you let it see how nice
life can be if you let it lie about the
people you're
killing lie about the people you're
killing drill RAP Community listen to me
heed my warning like clear like
Airbnb lie about the people you're
killing like the United States we've had
a good run and so can you good luck